bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans on
n'est pas sorti de l'auberge
aujourd'hui on prend la direction du
site de la réunion et plus exactement à
la plaine des grègues ici on cultive une
épice emblématique de la culture
culinaire locale et qu'il est possible
de fumer dans tous les bons plats locaux
j'ai nommé le curcuma mais mairie via
robert ici la maison du curcuma et je
pense qu'à cette heure ci doit déjà être
en train de travailler aux champs
alors on va le rejoint si vous voulez en
savoir un petit peu plus c'est parti
bonjour madame la maison du curcuma vous
connaissez pour descendre
ouais bah c'est juste par derrière
ok bon route je vous accompagne ses
adhérents choix
parra
puis tout contre vous
bonjour je cherche mes mails rien
n'aurait bougé pas j'arrive
comment savoir ça va ça va on est en
plein accord ambitieux donc c'est ce
terrain que tu extrait le fameux safran
pays oui oui donc l'aller quand les
feuilles sont tombées ça veut dire que
c'est à maturité d'accord donc là on va
les extraits de la terre ben pour le
retrouver après dans nos plats et une
superficie de combien la santé oms je
suis ses carnets aux cuma ah oui c'est
vrai que celle là ça défend quand même
en jusqu'à la route de beaucoup plus bas
donc au plus bas six hectares de curcuma
tu me dis de curcuma mais là on va
trouver aussi du gingembre de la route
parce que c'est un peu ce match
spécialité donc toutes les épices voit
la photo c'est moi c'est juste une
question pourquoi safran parce que il ya
toujours cette cette incompréhension il
ya des gens qui l'appelle turku mad
qu'il appelle safran pays est ce qu'une
petite histoire qui se strie ben nous on
a toujours appelé safran
mais jusqu'en 1986 elle nos
conditionnements c'est manquer ça prend
donc les métros qui mit en vacances ils
voyaient du safran à un prix vraiment
très très bas donc il achetait du
curcuma
voila voila il pensait revanche en
métropole et c'est là que la répression
des fraudes et un câble n'eurent nous
obligés d'appeler cuma bon on a quand
même gardé entre nous l'appellation soit
l'année à la réunion 10 apprend le
réunionnais qui en france depuis depuis
40 ans il connaît pas que ma nuit pour
lui c'est toujours à s'accroître cette
voie là bas si c'était du safran jaur et
eric taylor sur les mains on se croirait
dans le yukon c'est le jeune et souvent
à l'époque on trouvait même si les
billets la trace jaune ça voulait dire
que l'argent avait transité par la
plaine des grègues du coup là tu fais
quoi là c'est l'extraction la wii là on
enlève le curcuma de terrain parce que
voilà il faut dire aussi que le curcuma
c'est une racine est une racine et on le
récolte ou les deux en août septembre il
va les feuilles vont carrément tomber
mais on va pas rigoler je vais attendre
à des soins l'année suivante il vous
êtes combien travailler sur l'école
voilà avery colomer 5,5 battue c'est
quoi aujourd'hui ça m 6 il faut donner
le bon c'était le souverain la libyan
s'est soulevé un petit peu et je tapais
jusqu'à alors et du coup en fait je vais
récupérer quelques morceaux de curcuma
que je vais aller replanter
c'est daniela mandela jaune le sort de
faire ensuite du coup le voit encore sur
le champ qui en train de sécher et puis
on va passer à la troisième étape là on
enlève la terre donc ça veut dire que si
je pars de cela c'est le même principe
que talent fou de l'étape à terre vous
voyez en général on le met c'est mieux
le mettre sur un caillou pour ne pas
écraser les doigts voyez ça les
meilleurs se trouve dessous met d'accord
les mères c'est ce que vous voyez là
c'est ce qu'on a de plus gros finalement
voilà c'est celle qui sont avec les
racines et nous c'est à partir de sa
compatriote he est-ce qu'il ya qu à la
plaine des grègues corps et col du
curcuma ou est ce qu'on a c'est une
production qui se fait un peu partout à
la ben laden nous sommes la capitale du
cap may ça se faisait un peu partout
mais les gens ont carrément arrêter de
cultiver nous apprennent les règles on a
continué et c'est là que nous sommes
vraiment devenue la capitale du curcuma
avec une production de 94 certaines
années
j'ai remarqué que tu avais eu d'autres
arbres qui partager l'espace avec le
curcuma oui ben là j'ai mis de la dent
si c'est une variété de mandarine que
les gens ne connaissent pas vraiment
c'est une très très bonne mandarine
c'est l'une des meilleures quand tu me
donnes envie de goûter maintenant oui
mais là où d'autres petits voilà là ça
commence à fleurir donc il faudra
revenir l'année prochaine c'est à dire
que il ya plusieurs cultures peuvent
partager le même espace
oui là c'est une parcelle du document
avec des agrumes
de l'autre côté j'ai également les
agrumes l'attend gorle orange la
mandarine dans le champ de la route
et puis même dans la parcelle déjà jean
la maison
voilà on est donc sorti du champ et on a
ramené notre curcuma à l'atelier
donc là on est sur la même mer comme on
avait tout talent voilà on reconnaît
effectivement à toutes les petites
racines j'imagine que le but c'est quand
même d'en perdre le moins possible et ça
c'est paula après on va le dise s'il est
d'accord et pour obtenir l'huile
essentielle de kyo pleymo et l'huile
essentielle du curcuma
c est ce que ça a des vertus
particulières du curcuma oui aujourd'hui
on en parle beaucoup de duclos cuma
parce que c'est un anti inflammatoire un
anti cancérigène et souvent les gens me
disent mais oui vous devez vous devriez
pas avoir de cancer à la réunion parce
que vous consommez beaucoup de curcuma
mais la façon qu'on consomme le curcuma
on tue la partie médicinales est-ce que
tu le fais chauffer voilà on le met dans
l'huile chaude et des cons mais il ya
une petite odeur qui se dégage
et c'est là que c'est la claque mingqi
samba voyez donc la leko cette voie là
voilà ce qu'on appelle les cossette
elles seront déshydraté c'est marrant
parce que je m'attendais pas du tout un
travail complètement manuel les doigts
on va le passer à la machine
d'accord mais là ça va permettre vous
voyez de garder boyer tout cette petite
huile qui est là quand on passe à la
machine ça sera ça écrase la côte est
et tandis que la la ça va sécher donc si
je comprends bien c'est selon la
noblesse du produit tu va préférer le
travail et à la main voilà pour garder
cet aspect de luxe alors du coup une
fois qu'on a fini de découper les
cossette séchoir j'imagine qu'on va pas
tout découpé la surtout lui là bas il
n'a pas envie de filer un coup de main
donc j'imagine que l on a préparé
quelque chose là oui j'ai une clé iec
qui est prête donc on l'emmène demain
alors donc là c'est le ce soir oui en
chine quand même voilà il va sécher dans
le noir hier que l'eau qui va sortir a
eu d'accord vous vous en vous en rendez
pas compte mais il fait effectivement
voilà pas loin de 10 degrés de plus à
l'intérieur
donc est-ce qu'on accueille quelque
chose qui est déjà sec oui comme on râle
on va le broyer j'en ai là je t'en prie
voilà c'est decoset de luxe qui vont
être broyés alors est-ce qu'il peut on
peut utiliser sa en tant que tel c'est à
dire sans avoir à le broyer jeu infusion
en infusion donc je balance dans l'eau
chaude
voilà il est ça peut se convaincre que
ce qu'on savait combien de temps d'état
alors comme ça on peut le garder trois
quatre ans il n'y a pas de problème on
sait qu'on est d'accord le sexe bien sûr
et nous on le braille à mesure qu'on en
a besoin
alors c'est un temps froid du processus
impur elle arrivera en sucette
elle approchait de la mouture c'est
selon les cas me fais tuer
donc voilà donc on a découpé on a fait
l'échos est on a mis à sécher dans le
four on a broyé et là on va passer aux
conditions
bonjour madame je vous sers pas l'âme en
quoi que j'imagine que vous devez les
avoir plus ou moins dans le même état
que moi
voilà donc dans ce cas là donc du coup
voilà le produit fini curcuma de luxe
marque déposée par mémé et oui après
grand mère c'est faire un bon café on a
des mecs qui se veut le fer au choc
était peut-être facile suis désolé une
idée de combien de produits différents
que ce qui assure l'exploitation
je les transforme d'une façon ou d'une
autre oui c'est parce que c'est c'est ce
qu'on disait on n'a pas pu tout montrer
mais effectivement il ya aussi un
laboratoire et où tu confectionne ses
propres produits qui finissent par être
mise en vente ici que et donc du coup la
gamme pour faire une image de pour
donner une image tu as des huiles
essentielles alors au niveau curcuma bon
comme c'est le cas aux cuma ma
spécialité
donc j'ai du curcuma j'ai dû
du sirop de curcuma j'ai du vinaigre au
curcuma j'ai aussi de l'huile
essentielle au curcuma est ce qu il yad
autres prestations
est ce que tu proposes d'autres
approches quand les gens arrivent il ya
le petit film où ils vont voir la
transformation du curcuma est ensuite
bien cette étape-là au toit de ce
comptoir c'est la dégustation des
confitures des sirops des vinaigres et
tout ça parce que bon les gens ne
connaissent pas et si on ne déguste pas
on ne connaît pas alors qu'on parle de
la paix détaillé ce qu'il ya un endroit
que tu affectionnes particulièrement où
tu voudras m emmené par exemple
bah oui on a une superbe forêt de grippe
maya ou en été c'est vraiment super on a
du soleil vers les 10h30 14h il y en a
plus d'accord donc il ya quelques petits
kiosques et puis les gens qui
connaissent m bien s'y rendre et moins
de temps enfants pareil je m'en vais
avec la petite marmite et voilà ça donne
envie d'aller cette année
où
pour
pour vous
et comme maintenant qu'elle existe cette
espèce moi je les ai repris depuis 78
comme je suis fils unique que mon père
il était agriculteur mais bon lui
c'était plus les légumes et où il allait
seulement sur les marchés de gros à
fabien ils fêtaient des adducteurs du
mal il faisait déjà du cocma mais en
toute petite quantité moi quand je suis
arrivé binger voilà j'ai commencé le
curcuma et puis les agrumes et avança
bas avant ça j'étais pompiste j'ai
travaillé à l'abattoir j'ai fait pas mal
de métier j'avais même une petite boîte
de nuit dans les eaux away qui s'appelle
qui s'agrège les trois mousquetaires et
c'était vraiment les trois mousquetaires
il fallait que je reprenne
l'exploitation parce que mon père lui il
allait à la retraite et donc voilà j'ai
été élevé à l'époque également à
l'époque et ben maintenant j'ai beaucoup
diversifiés tout ce que je produis ben
voila je le transforme d'une façon ou
d'une autre et rapide au juste les dates
de la fête du curcuma en appel des grecs
la fatigue cuma c'est du 8 novembre au
11 juin
et puis bien sûr la maison du curcuma
elle est ouvert tous les jours du lundi
au dimanche
voila voila je te remercie pour aller
revoir et merci beaucoup à très très
vite bonne journée à vous voilà c'est
comme ça que se termine c'est dans ce
magnifique cadre que se termine ce
nouvel épisode on n'est pas sorti de
l'auberge
alors vous l'aurez compris si vous
voulez en savoir un petit peu plus sur
le curcuma c'est ici à la plaine des
grègues que ça se passe à la maison du
curcuma bien évidemment n'hésitez
absolument pas un gros plus d'ailleurs à
mémé à toute son équipe pour leur
hospitalité pour l'ambiance qui règne et
pour tout était couverte c'est à dire
gustatives ya plein de choses que je
n'avais jamais goûté et j'imagine que
pour vous c'est exactement la même chose
en ce qui me concerne je vais continuer
ma petite rando ici parce qu'il n'y a
pas que le curcuma avoir à la plaine des
grègues en ce qui nous concerne on se
retrouve très très vite sur les routes
de la réunion allait à plus
une